[Music]
our first speaker
for this afternoon will be dewey
[Applause]
dunnington
hi this is this is a lot of people this
is great
so i'm here today to talk to you about
programming with gt plot 2. i imagine
that all of you
i use g plot 2 or many of you use ggplot
2.
it's a fantastic package for making
graphics and a lot of times
there are times you need to do that in a
function or in a shiny app or in a
parameterized report
or in a package and those are all great
uses of ggplot2
and there's some some different
paradigms around how to do that and i
just wanted
to talk about that so my my story starts
as many
great books and movies have started uh
with the reverse dependency check
so reverse dependency checks are
something that the ggplot2 team does
when we release
or preparing or release for uh for duty
plot
and there's over 1500 packages that
directly import or depend on
ggplot2 and over 2500 that use it in
the suggests uh on a package so there's
a lot
of ggplot code on cran um and that's
great for us because it means that there
are a lot of
a lot of use cases that are that are
considered that we didn't actually
know about necessarily so we run
all of the command checks with the old
version of the package and command
checks with a new version of the package
and see which packages broke and
sometimes that's our fault and sometimes
there are some things in other packages
but for the most part
as a fresh ggplot2 intern over the
summer
it was my job to go through all the
packages that that we broke
and through doing that i was able to
read a lot of gt plot to code and
realize that there were a lot of
problems that
that people were trying to solve in
packages that we hadn't ever documented
and also in some cases that like we
hadn't made possible
and so the result of that was this
vignette using ggplot2 in packages it's
available on the
the development version of the ddplot 2
package down site the main site for
gdgplot2 and
the release of ddplot2 the next version
is coming i am told
and then it will be on the the main gt
plot 2 website
but this talk is largely derived from
that and so i'd encourage you to read it
if you're
if you'd like to know more so i'm going
to start with
something much like the gg plot that is
an r for data science this is one of the
first plots that many people make in r
uh and if not the first r code that they
ever type but this is using the
the mpg package it's a bunch of cars and
so my 2008 ford ranger was it was a four
wheel drive car
and uh it had a huge engine and terrible
gas mileage and and so it's
uh down here uh my crosstrek that i
currently drive is up here somewhere
uh smaller engine a bit better gas
mileage
and the 80cc scooter that i sometimes
drive is
off the chart and off the chart
excellent gas mileage very very small
engine
sounds like a lot more so that's what
we're looking at here
and there's a couple things this is a
good plot just to illustrate some of the
problems that i noticed were
people were trying to solve so
for a variety of reasons you might start
out with something like this maybe it's
a parameterized report
so you've got something in our markdown
you set it up so that you can
you can change what the color variable
might be like maybe you don't want it to
be the class of the car maybe you want
it to be something else
and also you might want to change how
the uh how the points are grouped in
facets
and so you have a facet variable in this
case we're using the drv variable
whether it's four wheel drive front
wheel drive
that kind of thing but we have this uh
mapping and facet specification that
uses tidy evaluation so we've
ggplot knows that that class for example
is
to look for it in the mpg data set
because that's the plot data
and it knows to look for the drv
variable in
mpg because that's the plot data
but you can't just if you if you put a
string in there it
won't do what you expect it to do
so uh the best way i think to solve this
problem is to use the dot data pronoun
to do that and pronoun is a is a a fancy
word for
the fact that ggplot now knows that data
is a stand-in
for mpg so it's a sand-in for the layer
data for the plot data
and so you can specify these things and
use them much like you would
a data frame you can subset them with
the double brackets
you can use the dollar sign which i'll
show a bit later and you can do that
both with a facet specification
and with a mapping so this is
really powerful and this lets us use a
syntax that we
sort of expect in a mapping and in a
facet specification
uh so then you can you can make a
function around it and this
this isn't artificial by the way this is
actually how i made uh this
is the process that i go through when i
when i make a function for gt plot so
uh so the order is is uh kind of helpful
i think
so you can put it in a function we can
pass color variable in as arguments
uh and then we can call that function
and we we get a plot
so that's a useful way to to simplify
making possibly a bunch of plots or
making plots in our markdown report
so we've got this function now it's got
some arguments those arguments are
what we expect them to be
but it doesn't quite work because we
actually can't remove uh
the color mapping so if we back to this
plot what if we don't actually want
color in there and there's lots of
reasons that you might want to do that
you've got a check box and a shiny app
or
or in a parameterized report you want it
to to not
make things colored so
currently that doesn't work so we have
to go back to the code and change some
things
so the best way i think to solve this
problem is
to take this mapping here so this is
this is what we're doing with the
mapping
and just move that up so we can't modify
it if it's not
on its own and it's a bit simpler to
bring it up top so that we don't have to
modify it within
uh the geom point function it's a bit
cleaner to read
and then we can we can test for if the
color variable is null
and then we can modify the mapping uh
based on that
and so this is a pretty common problem
that i've had personally with
programming with ggplot2 and so i think
it's a good pattern where you put your
mapping up top
and you can modify that as you go
depending on what you're
trying to do so that's all well and good
but we still can't remove
the facet so we've got we've got three
panels
and maybe we don't actually want any
panels maybe we want to give
a user of a shiny app an option to say
okay don't actually
group this by anything maybe we just uh
would like to have just one plot
so again back to our uh back to our code
and i think that the best way to solve
this problem is to
the facet was previously at the bottom
it's just to move that up a little bit
so again we can
we can work with it a bit easier and we
can keep the structure of the plot at
the bottom of the function so that
it stays clear exactly what what the
plot is made up of
and then we can test whether the facet
variable is null
and we can use this trick with ggplot
which i think is highly underused
where you can add null to a ggplot and
it changes nothing
and you think you think that that's not
actually that useful but it's really
useful in a situation like this
because without it you'd have to define
two gigi plots
you wouldn't be able to just say okay i
don't want to add anything to the plot
in a certain case
so i think this conditional adding of
possibly nothing to a plot
is really powerful and it really helps
clean up your actual gdpr specification
so that interns like me when i'm reading
your code it's it's a bit easier to
to read mostly for you it's mostly for
you
so now we've successfully have a
slightly less interesting plot
but but the point is we can actually
modify now a couple of different options
about it we could add the color back in
if we wanted to
and it still wouldn't give us any panels
so i think that the big take homes here
for just using ggplot in a function
is that you can use dot data much like a
data frame
within aes so you can use it as a
stand-in for that layer data
that you want to map and it follows all
the regular rules
within the double brackets so that you
can put variable names in there
that might be inputs in a shiny app or
they might be
they might be parameterized report
variables or even just
in a function that you made for yourself
because you want to make a whole lot of
plots that works both in aes
and vars
the second thing that i think is is
really helpful for just using ggplot in
a function is
uh using the fact that adding null to
the end of a gt plot does nothing
and that's really helpful if you might
want to add something and you might not
it helps keep your actual specification
of a gg plot
pretty clean and something that i didn't
show an example of but that's similarly
useful is that you can add a list of
things
to a dg plot and it will add all of them
in the list
sequentially so that's pretty useful
it's a bit easier to programmatically
modify lists than to programmatically
modify
adding a bunch of things together so
that's a
another nice trick that you might be
able to use in specifying some of your
plots
so if you are just making a function
then that is that's as far as you need
to go but if you want to use
ggplot2 in a package there are some
other steps that
that you need to take there's lots of
reasons that you might want to make a
little package maybe you'd like to put
it on
github and let your friends install it
or maybe you want to submit it to cram
so there's a couple more constraints
that come with that this is the plot mpg
package i'll show you a link to the
slides at the end of the the talk and
you can see this little tiny package
it has one function the plot mpg
function and it
lets you specify a color mapping that
lets you specify
a facet variable so
that's what it looks like and if we
start oh sorry
very important digression
i didn't the slide isn't in there
because of any of your functions your
functions are fantastic
this slide is in there because recently
when i was making this talk
uh i was faced with about 400 lines of
conditional plotting code
that i'd put in a package for it was
ggplot2
lots of if statements i was trying to
make the perfect plot uh for plotting
this very
particular type of of uh data about mud
because that's what i do
and the uh what i realized when i was
going through this code is that
really what it boiled down to was like
four lines of a gg plot like
there was like really four lines of
ggplot code that took
hundreds of lines to handle all of the
edge cases
about various types of data that could
end up there and so my solution to that
was actually to make a vignette
first and also to put examples uh in
a really really good data generating
function
so what that ended up with is actually
really good documentation and
i don't think that there was anybody
that was that could make any
less good plots i think that it actually
resulted in a far more
far better package and it was a lot
easier for me to test because i had this
really great
data generating function so i think it's
worth considering that
and if even if you still would like a
plot function and you probably would
still like a plot function
if you do both of those things then you
can make something that's easier
to test
so this is the function that we that we
started with
so this is this is a great function but
it won't work necessarily in a package
so when you refer to anything in a
package you have to be really explicit
about where it comes from
and i know that many of you probably
know this it's it's a
general package development but you can
use the colon colon
to refer to something in a really
particular package but you can also do
this thing where you import
from ggplot2 and you can import those
functions
to use them within your package without
having to do the ggplot2
colon colon thing sometimes you do have
to do that with datasets you always have
to
press preface it with the the package
name beforehand
but this is a really great trick that
you can use within a package to keep
your code looking clean
and if you use ggplot2 a lot then this
will keep your ggplot2 looking really
clean inside the package and a lot
easier to read
again i was an intern i read a lot of
code and in the 400 lines of code that i
just removed
gdpot 2 colon colon i did a search
before i did it it showed up like 157
times
so so this is a way to keep it a little
bit cleaner
and then when you run the documentation
it'll spit that into your your namespace
and you can keep your code very similar
to what it was before
but we're going to get a problem so i i
don't know if the if you guys have
experienced this but
when i get a little x at the bottom of
our command check then
my heart goes races a little bit and i
and i start to question my existence
uh it's but in this case we're getting
three errors
that don't actually affect whether the
function works or not
but there's something that that r
doesn't know about the function that we
have to tell it explicitly
so in this case we've got three things
that it that our thinks that aren't
defined
uh so if you're following along there
this displacement variable
this highway variable and the dot data
variable
so these are things that are very
correctly has not detected in
some assigned statement before that
and gdpr2 is smart enough to know that
these things are in your layer data
bar doesn't know that so we can
explicitly tell it that using the dot
data
pronoun again so this is the
new and improved code where we're using
data as something like a data frame that
we can use the dollar sign
to extract a variable out of it
and that will that will help with the or
that will remove the command check
note so we also you'll notice that i had
to import from our laying dot data
data we can't do that with because it's
special within
the mapping but if we do this then it
will make that problem go away
and so we'll get that that little check
note to disappear
and your heart can fill with joy when
you run the r command check
so a final thing that i that i want to
talk about is testing so
if you followed my advice earlier and
made a really really good
data generating function so a function
that returned a data frame that you can
pass directly into ggplot2
then you can test that reasonably well
and
if you saw jenny bryan's talk this
morning you had a little test that
introduction
and you can use something called vdiffer
which is a package by leonel henry
i was part of the tidyverse team to
actually test
the visual output so you can't always
test something programmatically and
invest a lot of times with a plot you
shouldn't
you shouldn't reach into a plot object
and try and test something
it's much better and it's much more
realistic honestly to the end point
to test the image that got generated so
in ggplot2 we use this and i think there
are hundreds of
plots that we have to check and if we
had to do that manually
we might not do them or we might not do
it as well or we might miss something
so we use the vdiffer package to
generate some version of record for
every single one of those figures
and then when we run the test it checks
that every single one of those figures
is identical
so you can use it much like another
expectation where we have this expect
doppelganger
where we're expecting this plot mpg
function as it's called
to generate the same thing as some
version we have on file
and so you can make the version on file
by running this
this little function in the vdiffer
package and that will run all of your
tests collect all the dopplegangers
and spit out something that looks like
this
where any of your new cases it'll asks
you to validate so it'll say yes this is
the version that i want on file
but if any of them are mismatched it
will also show you the two versions so
you can see
what changed so whether that's a change
in your code that induced a change in a
figure
or whether it's a change in our code and
ggplot choose code that
induced a change in your figure you can
see what the change was and whether or
not
that is something that that is
meaningful to you in which case
you can tell us or change your code or
whether it's something that is so small
that
it doesn't matter to you and and then
you can generate a new version of record
uh so i think that that is a really
powerful tool
and it's something that i've just
started to move any package that i do to
to use it doesn't have to be duty plot2
it can do lots of other formats
and it's fantastic package so
using ggplot2 in a package we can we can
use the double colon
that you might be familiar with to refer
to objects in ggplot2 whether they're
functions or datasets
and then we can also use this import
from syntax
so we can actually import specific
functions from ggplot2 so that we don't
have to use
ggplot2 colon colon so that your first
line doesn't have to be ggplot2 colon
colon
opening parentheses ggplot2 colon colon
aes
opening parentheses it gets very dirty
very quick
the second is we can use the data within
a mapping or a facet spec we can use
that
to avoid command check problems with a
very variable not being defined
and finally you can test everyone should
be testing we love testing
and you can test graphical output using
the vdiffer package
and so this is a bit of a toy example
that i did it's the the mpg data set
there's a reason that there's not a plot
mpg package
because people don't need help plotting
that data set
but you might need help plotting all of
the canadian election results starting
in 1867.
this is something i did right after the
canadian election we do have elections
it's uh but even though we're ruled by
the queen very technically
uh but this is every election since 1867
and as you might imagine it's pretty
useful to have a plot function for that
and it's useful to have a data
generating function and there's a number
of other problems that this package
solves
that i didn't have time to go into in
the talk and so if you're interested i'd
encourage you to check it out it's a
fairly minimal package
and i'd be happy to have any questions
if you if you look at it and would like
to
ask me about them so that is all i had
i'd encourage you to check out the
vignette if this is something that you
think you're going to do
a lot and i'm also very happy to answer
any questions now or or later or on
github or on twitter
or any one of the things so thank you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so we have maybe two minutes for a
couple quick questions if you're an
animal
okay great so uh it looks like a number
of people in the audience were
interested in
um your your use of variable quoting
and maybe why uh
why not or what about tidy eval and
yeah sure so what i talked about is tidy
eval the dot data pronoun
is tidy eval but if you're talking about
the
the double braces or whether you're
talking about the double exclamation
point
those are things that you can use if you
want your functions to use
the same tidy evaluation semantics a lot
of times you actually don't want that
you don't actually want
your function to to do something
non-standard because a lot of people
don't expect
that so i think that there are a lot of
things that are good about that and
there's a lot of really great material
by hadley and others
but this is one of the ways that you can
if you don't happen to do that
that you can make that happen
awesome uh another question here uh
could you explain the difference between
using
null and geom blank sure
so you can use geom blank but john blank
actually does do something
uh jam blank will still make the the
limits of the axis
uh do something and so that's why i was
adding null
there's also so this is a geometry and
geom blank is a perfectly
good way or it might be to do what you
want to do but if you have a scale that
you might
want to add or might not uh then there
is no scale blank
uh so null is a stand-in for anything uh
blank it's just like that that piece of
the the plot never happened
awesome maybe one more here and i'm not
sure if you'll
understand or if you'll need more
context but how do you address the test
brittleness when using
vdiffer sorry the test brutalness
brittleness
brittleness yeah yeah so there's a lot
of great material on that
on on vdiffer as a monitoring tool and
not necessarily a testing tool
so it's sort of designed to be brittle
it's designed to fail very easily
when there's any little tiny change
because it really does check the svg
that was printed out if there's when i
was rewriting the axes i ran into a
problem where i drew the tick marks in
the opposite direction and it detected
that
and that is a good thing from our
perspective so by default it doesn't
run those tests on cran so you don't
have to worry about your package failing
on cran because of that
but it does run them on travis if you're
using travis by default
and that is actually really helpful to
make sure that your figures aren't
different on some other operating system
so it is brittle but it's i think it's
brittle by design and i think that that
is a good thing
there are some ways to get around not
running it on certain platforms if you
think that that's a problem
so i think that there's there's some i
think it's still worth doing
awesome thank you so much dewey please
join me in and thank you
one more time
you